Well, it's finally here.
It's been so long and yet the last four years,
in a sense, have flown by.
It's Election Day and I could say many different
things today.
And if I said anything targeted at affecting
how or whether you vote, it would likely be
too late because most people have already
voted with early voting and absentee ballots.
And by the time today's show goes out, my
guess is something like 95 percent will have
already voted.
Just remaining with the last few to vote in
person in the second half of today.
And the reality is that at this point, this
election has been decided.
We won't know the results until the ballots
are counted.
Hopefully every single ballot will be counted.
That's an entire other issue that we've been
dealing with this election.
But this is one of the largest inflection
points, not just in American, but in global
politics that I've lived through.
And certainly the biggest inflection point
that I've covered since starting The David
Pakman Show years and years ago.
It is not just the presidency that is up for
grabs tonight.
Yes, in a literal sense, it is also the Senate.
We don't know whether Republicans will retain
control or not.
It is also the House of Representatives, although
Democrats are not just expected to retain
control there, but even to expand the Democratic
majority in the House of Representatives.
But it is really I don't want to be hyperbolic,
but there's and I'm not.
But it sounds like hyperbolic language.
The next 10 to 20 years of American politics
and global politics, I believe, are tied up
in the results today that we will start to
get tonight the future of the United States
as either part of the solution or part of
the problem on climate depends on whether
Donald Trump gets reelected today and whether
Democrats take the Senate today.
The future of the American reputation and
by extension, the experience that all of us
have in the world, both when we are in the
United States and when we travel elsewhere.
That is at stake today.
And also at stake today is whether we start
to disassemble this mind virus that is Trump
ism or whether it is reinforced and perpetuated
over the next four years, which would be an
unconscionable disaster.
Donald Trump is uniquely unqualified to be
president of the United States at any time.
But there could be no worse time for such
an unqualified and incompetent president than
right now.
We've been faced with a 100 year global pandemic.
Any other American president from the last
hundred years would have better handled this
pandemic.
And in fact, I would suggest that just about
any thinking person would have better handled
this pandemic by stepping aside and saying,
I know enough to know when I don't know and
I'm going to let the experts handle this.
It's almost as if saying nothing and just
saying I'm going to let other people handle
handle it would have been better and in fact,
it would have been better.
And Donald Trump deserves to be powerfully
repudiated and removed because of his mishandling
of the pandemic.
We are rapidly approaching a record hurricane
season caused by many things.
One component of which is believed to be warmer
oceans, partially as a result of American
and human activity on planet Earth.
It is the United States is a polluter.
It is humans as polluters.
That is a factor in this.
Worse, potentially worse than ever.
Hurricane season.
And we have a president who has said climate
change is a Chinese hoax meant to bolster
the Chinese manufacturing industry.
We have an economic crisis which will likely
get worse before it gets better with the third
spike of Corona virus coming in the United
States.
And we have a president who knows nothing
about economics, who called his later to be
indicted national security adviser in the
middle of the night to say, hey, is a strong
dollar good or bad for the United States?
That's who is handling the economic situation.
We've had Great Depression like unemployment
numbers, GDP declines that even with the partial
recovery of the third quarter, leave us eight
percent shy of where we were at the start
of the pandemic.
Eight percent when you talk about GDP is a
monstrous number.
And we have a global community that started
by laughing at us, but they're not laughing
anymore.
They are actually scared and pitying us.
Listen to the foreign callers who called into
my streams over the last week from Austria
and Argentina and Australia and Spain, the
United.
Kingdom, France, where else?
Many, many places they are scared of Trump
and they fear for our futures.
There would be no time in American history
where Donald Trump would have been a good
president.
But there are times in American history where
he could have been a more benign annoyance.
There is no time in American history worse
than right now for a president that has so
weaponized the worst of the electorate and
has so coalesced the most disgusting and violent
instances of the American right wing.
We tried the businessman President Mitt Romney,
tried to do it, and the country was very soundly
said, no, we are reelecting Barack Obama.
We now tried the businessman president and
it failed.
Bad relationships need a clean end and we
can elect a different spouse today for lack
of a better term and get a clean break on
January 20th.
You don't usually get the divorce and the
new marriage on the same day, but we actually
have that opportunity.
I don't know who's ultimately going to win
tonight.
I don't know when we will ultimately know
the results and win or lose tonight unless
we fix our education, our culture of our financial
systems.
We aren't going to fix the problem of 30,
40, 50, 60 million people who not only voted
for Donald Trump four years ago, but after
seeing what he did for the last four years,
said, give me another four.
OK. Trump ism does not disappear with Trump,
whether he leaves in two and a half months
or four years and two and a half months.
If there are no consequences for the disgusting,
bad faith politics that we've seen this cycle,
and in fact, if we don't deal with that, it
could continue indefinitely.
It could even be the downfall of the country.
And I know many will say the United States
could never have a downfall.
It's too powerful.
Every empire in the midst would say we will
last forever.
And just about every such empire did eventually
fall.
But we're getting ahead of ourselves.
Did you vote?
Is the.
If the answer.
Yes.
If the answer is yes, then you've done your
part.
Did you tell people you should vote?
And here's why you should vote for Joe Biden
or some combination, some version of that.
We have to be OK.
Knowing we've done what we can do, we ultimately
don't control the fact that there are more
than 60 million people in this country likely
to vote vote to reelect Donald Trump.
But for today, the focus is let's remove Trump.
Let's take control of the Senate back.
Let's open the door to starting to fix some
of these issues.
The counterpoint.
The alternative is very ugly.
And it's not clear to me that our democracy
can withstand another four years of Trump.
The country will withstand four more years
of Trump, but will our democracy?
And by the way, another four years of Trump
opens the door to another Trump in 2024.
It could be literally another Trump like Donald
Trump Junior or Ivanka Trump.
It could just be a Trump like Republican.
Both would be a disaster.
So today is not about reminding you about
bleach injections.
Drawing on hurricane maps with sharpies like
the one I have here, or lying again and again
and again and again and again, as he has done
for so long.
This is merely about saying to the world through
the results that we will hopefully get today.
Enough of us realize the mistake that was
made in 2016.
Some of us made a mistake by actually voting
for Trump, not me, but some of us did.
Some of us made a mistake by not voting at
all.
We realized that mistake and we are test taking
not even step one, but step zero point five
in the direction of fix fixing it.
We're trying to get the ball back to try to
put some points on the board in the next couple
of years.
I hope everyone in the audience has voted.
We will be hopefully all together tonight
as the results start to come in.
We may not know everything by by midnight
tonight, but we will know quite a bit.
And we will do our best to get you ready today
for the next 24 hours.
I will give you my final predictions reminder.
I will be live tonight, starting with the
first results at 7:00 p.m. Eastern Time.
We will be monitoring all of the different
networks.
We will have maps.
We will have spreadsheets.
We will have Meems and songs and calls and
the entire thing.
So join me tonight on YouTube, Twitch or Facebook.
Let's now get into what I am predicting we
will see tonight.